da habe ich gedacht ist eine super idee
wenn ich mir in also einfach ein ganz
normales nicht gekochtes ei im
kühlschrank holen und das ausbrüten an
ihrem zimmer das hat dann komischerweise
nicht funktioniert und ich hatte einfach
mal drei wochen oder so bei mir unter
der decke mit im bett und komisch
angefangen zu stehen alles
weggeschmissen
das ist falsch leute und herzlich
willkommen zur sechsten folge fand war
oder alt zusammen mit broken fonds tvh
gefängnis wandere direct x games
irgendwas gekürzt auf ihr ist klar dass
wir nachher alles bricht ab
wir laufen einfach alle im kreisgebiet
nein ich könnte wirklich vergessen was
genau ist wieder eingefangen hat
warum hat der meint er ist wieder da
kommt so also ja okay so leicht
bekleidete frauen ein bisschen
und dann haben wir noch nie einem
stripclub city behindert alter und dann
haben wir es halt so weil unser tisch da
wurde sonst weggeputzt alter haben wir
zwei gruppen aufgeteilt sind
mainz laufhaus gegangen gucken mal
gewalt in einer anderen gruppe wir waren
zu viert ging es oder durch und diese
führten sind ihr schon so richtig
na siehst du hast du bock navis hecken
ein kollege einfach im scherz los
gemacht und mit dem schnitt nach einfach
zu behandeln wie viel kostet er jetzt
einmal geschlechtsverkehr man ja 50 euro
ja aber ich muss sagen mein penis ist
nicht mehr so groß da wirst du nicht so
viel spüren
für mich 30 machen die ganze ist eine
scheiße
ja bist mir einen blasen ja 20 euro ja
könig ein bisschen bisschen günstiger
machen
ich hab nur noch zehn euro dabei und die
10 euro würde ich dir schenken
du kannst wie die auch einfach so geben
nein ich möchte geleistet haben ja also
das hatte
im kaufhaus und kollegen versucht hat zu
verhandeln
also um konkreter macht den gleichen
stand verbringt ist es auf jeden fall
war dass wir da waren und dass die dann
zusammen da durchlauf ausgegangen dass
ich bis dahin stimme sich keine ahnung
und ich sagte okay es war so jung ich
wollte erstmal schlagen
das ist nico von nikos einfach er hat
auch einfach schon die ganze zeit gesagt
dass nichts besser bekannt als kanal ok
ich hatte meine freundin falsch ich
hatte eine freundin und wir waren zwölf
jahre alte liebe beziehung halt so und
wir saßen halt auf seiner brücke wo es
aber halt nur fahrradfahrer darüber
können und da war ich mal nicht mit ihr
zusammen sondern ich wollte da küsst und
zu sagen ich liebe dich schön
und ich bin eiskalt wir saßen da und ich
bin einfach ins wasser gefallen von
dieser brücke also das war nur zwei
meter oder so aber ich bin einfach ins
wasser gefallen und sie ist hinterher
gesprungen und dann machen wir dort
gebadet und letztendlich habe ich solche
küsst aber ich bin ich bin halt einfach
so es sei denn die kaputt gegangen
nein da dachte ich noch kein händler 12
technics dabei ich hatte nur geld und
der it comes to the beatles die für
bücher setzt haben schon drei
gut also als ich jung war keine ahnung
wie alt vielleicht sechs bin ich durch
gleich mit kollegen feiern war schon da
hab ich irgendwie das ist eine super
idee wenn ich mir in also einfach so ein
ganz normales nicht gekochtes ei im
kühlschrank holen und das ausbrüten bei
mir im zimmer
es hat dann komischerweise nicht
funktioniert und ich hatte einfach mal
drei wochen oder so nicht bei mir unter
der decke mit im bett und komisch
angefangen zu stehen weggeschmissen
dann habe ich das einfach aus dem
fenster geschmissen und ich glaube die
rache ich könnte nicht auf das
grundstück von den geflogen ist kann
weil irgendjemand mal ein ei gegen mein
fenster das stimmt darf es noch das alte
zimmer ja genau das also mein jetziges
zimmer zeigt zu können was aber da hätte
das durchaus daher ich wünsche mir
einfach ich wünsche mir einfach dass es
wahr ist dass er versuchen dass es
falsch ist falsch nein wie abartig
wissen denn
mit 8
ich habe meinen kollegen
ich musste passen und ich höre ich
allein aufs klo zu gehen wie sowieso
mädchen alter und dann ist halt ein
kollege mit gekommen august also zwei
normale toiletten also die dann halt
eine trennwand dazwischen nahmen die
stars und ich war halt an dem tag das
war okay und ich war an die pack sowas
von zu alter dabei kann das bestätigen
sicherlich richtig
das kann eine kollege du mit deiner hand
diese trends noch keinem erzählen so
dicht alter ich hab einfach wirklich in
meinem himmel dagegen
altwasser crafter warte warte warte noch
nicht gucken da ich gucke ich guck ich
gucke nicht für mich sonst wäre ich sage
außerdem nehme ich überhaupt auf dem
vogel ich sage mein ladekabel ist
heruntergefallen lüge ich sage es ist ja
ich sag das ist eine lüge
ja hab deinen schwanz daraus ich war
schon draußen mal sie wie viele bücher
hast du ich habe 30
ich hab mir jemand los geht's ok also
ich war ein baby und das walbaby ich war
ich war welcher nicht eins oder zwei
nein es hat mir meine mutter letztes
erzählt weil ich meinte wen welche
witzige geschichten gibt es solche
walbaby also ich verhalten baby und es
war der erste abend zu hause nach meiner
geburt also ich war immer was jedoch
nicht 1 da wird dann stimmt dann war ich
da nicht angst hat keine ahnung wie
halte ich war jedenfalls meine mutter
haben halt frisch geduscht dann aus der
dusche und wollte mich dann halt wickeln
und die zog die windel halt die alte
windel von mir weg und habe mich dann
hoch gehoben und dann auf einmal
also ich hatte durchfälle und dann kann
so ein riesiger strom scheiße aussieht
raus und lieber frisch geduscht in
wacken braun
das ist nicht mehr meine geschichte das
war die von thomas kessinger also er hat
seine riege nicht ob ein buch das ihr
die schlechteste aller zeit ich kann das
gar nicht mehr geöffnet
ich kann echt nichts mehr machen freunde
damals in der schule meist noch einmal
auf wieso bin ich traurig und kennt ihr
das beim sport wenn man so läuft ja dann
der pimmel immer durch die gegend kriegt
ja scheiße war zwei boxer aber nur wenn
ich montags und mittwochs
ich sag ja ja hab zwei bücher ich hab
mich vertraut die mir oder solcon
crafter seine rausholen ich vertraue dir
ist ja ok welchen namen soll ich zuerst
fragen der erst jüngst hatte kopp ist
donald übertreibt bitte ja ich habe
jetzt mein rechtes jetzt größer in
meiner kiste
ich mach das anders wird war der fall
schreibt e-mails an die eingeblendeten
adressen oder nicht verwendete adressen
ein die an der beschreibung stehen
einfach kräftig einen dritten der fig 8
ich kann das auch ein blenden so oben
eingeblendet was von uns allen liegt
doch jetzt wollte ich ja mein denken das
nächste folge bei uns also ich mache
weil die leider ist er nicht verstehen
ohne spaß aber die sogar wirklichkeit ja
warum nicht
es kann ja mal abwechselnd werden die
das jetzt noch nicht durchblickt haben
mit der bahn oder fahrrad wäre auch
zusammen eine playlist oder haben wir
haben wir noch nicht glauben ich bin eh
trier euch alle anderen in der nächsten
folge ich schwöre ich habe
ich werde erst hat mich richtig
anstrengen ich werde wird recherchieren
über euer leben ich werde die nsa
einfach fragen alles klar
die andere sache die merkel fragen wie
was ist wenn es euch gefallen hat dürfte
einen daumen hoch geben wie gesagt e
mails wie die verrückten august so ein
arschloch von klima herrsche nicht
hinein